good morning Hank it's Monday March 29th
2010 it's tax season which means that I
must once again for the 32nd consecutive
year report to the Internal Revenue
Service that I have failed to garner any
fishing boat proceeds French the llama
fishing boat proceeds or the unicorns of
my tax return and now Hank having
alienated all our new viewers I begin
the video so Hank I have a bad habit of
googling myself have a holden caulfield
hat how did you get here so the other
day I was googling myself and I
discovered something absolutely
incredibly important to discuss which is
that in a few days I have a book coming
out that I co-wrote with David Levithan
and we are going on tour and some of the
events on the tour ticketed others are
not to find out if yours is ticketed go
to the link in the dooblydoo right hank
so i discovered something pretty
incredible and it wasn't that there is a
guy named John Green who is one of the
Four Horsemen of Sasquatch eree
that I already knew because one time I
read an article for Mental Floss
magazine in which I talked about the
fact that Bigfoot is you know fictional
and I totally got a letter from famous
Bigfoot apologist John Green who said my
anti Bigfoot propaganda with besmirching
the good name of John Green's everywhere
right so that is not what I discovered
what I discovered this is kind of
annoying the castle how did hold and
deal with the tassel what I discovered
is that a line I wrote years ago in my
book an abundance of katherines has kind
of gone viral on Twitter it's been
tweeted more than 10,000 times the line
is chase Enzo ha la veta co mañana Pro
via farik is so difficult oh I don't
speak Italian the line is what is the
point of being alive if you don't at
least try to do something remarkable
which I will admit I did write in this
book but as anyone who's read it knows I
was kidding
that's something Colin singleton the
main character the book is kind of a
child prodigy says at the beginning of
the book and he must spend the entire
book learning his bull I don't know how
it looks on the screen there on YouTube
but in the viewfinder it looks a little
bit like a lady hat but I promise it is
not it is the actual replica the actual
replica of a hat worn by a fictional
character in a novel anyway Hank this
phenomenon it seems to me is near
Universal in the Internet age which is
that instead of people being misquoted
they are Mis contextualized it's
impossible to pull a line or a sentence
or even a chapter from a book and
understand the meaning of that section
because as much as it pains us in this
soundbite e twittering world text means
nothing without its context for instance
Holden Caulfield's red hunting cap
doesn't really make any sense until you
have the
one text telling you that it's the same
color as his dead brothers hair look
she's wearing a hat it's not a metaphor
I just thought it was funny anyway the
whole thing made me think about
something maybe our favorite quotation
say more about us than they say about
the stories and people were quoting so
nerdfighters what's your favorite quote
leave it down below in comments and then
let's think about what that says about
us I mean how did Holden Caulfield deal
with the tassel issue is that ever
covered in the text my favorite quote of
the moment is from Robert Frost the only
way out is through I don't know what
that says about me but I'm sure he'll
tell me in comments and then we'll all
tell each other what our quote say about
each other okay
gotta get rid of this daesil so annoying
Hank I'll see you on Wednesday from some
angles it's a lady head and then from
some angles it's like it's a me Mario